pokemon day 2022 is bringing a week's
worth of announcements rainbow six siege
is getting some new content and more
the pokemon company announced its plans
for the annual pokemon day fan
celebration and this year it's not
limited to a single day the company
announced that instead we'll see a
week's worth of announcements from
across the franchise leading up to the
actual date of february 27th you'll be
able to follow the reveals on the
brand's social media channels the merch
store pokemon center will be unveiling
new products throughout the week as well
starting with today's reveal of custom
skateboards from bear walker featuring
mew and gyarados the company also says
you can check out pokemon tv for curated
collections of fan favorite episodes and
movies pokemon day takes place every
year on february 27 to mark the
anniversary of the release of the
original pokemon red and pokemon green
in japan in 1996.
last year 2021 marked the 25th
anniversary of pokemon
ubisoft is kicking off rainbow six
siege's first season of the year with a
bang it's called demon veil and it's
adding a new map and permanent game mode
to the competitive shooter along with a
new operator who can rebuild defenses
azami is a defender with medium speed
and health zombie is unremarkable save
for her gadget the kiba barrier the
operator can throw kunai that releases
gas in a small circle where they land
that gas then solidifies into a
bulletproof surface providing quick
cover
beyond creating cover for players a
zombie's gadget offers players a brand
new defensive option in rainbow six
siege using her kiba barrier holes on
any surface can easily be patched
including on ceilings giving players
protection against enemies attacking
from both above and below of course a
zombie can also be countered by other
operators specifically any equipped with
grenade launchers her keepa barrier
gadgets can be destroyed by either a
single explosion or three melee attacks
along with new content rainbow six
siege's upcoming season will also add
substantial gameplay changes along with
team deathmatch becoming a permanent
addition to the game attacker repick is
also coming to each game mode both
ranked and unranked as its name implies
attacker repic will let attackers change
their operator during the preparation
phase of any match letting teams change
their strategy as the game goes on
ubisoft hasn't revealed a release date
for demonville yet but players can get
in on the action starting today test
servers for the game are currently
hosting an early build of rainbow 60
just next season for players to try out
capcom has officially announced street
fighter 6 the next entry in its popular
fighting series a teaser trailer shows a
very shredded looking ryu preparing to
fight luke a dlc character from street
fighter 5. there is also a close-up of
feat in case that's of any interest to
you
in an all-caps announcement post capcom
said here comes a new street fighter
more news about the game is expected to
come this summer as of yet capcom has
not announced platforms or a release
date nor do we know anything about what
gameplay changes or improvements can be
expected street fighter 5 was released
in february of 2016 so it just recently
marked its 6th anniversary the game has
sold more than 6 million copies while
presumably it's made lots of money from
dlc sales too
capcom veteran and long time street
fighter producer yoshi noriono recently
left the company so street fighter 6
will be produced without his involvement
in a big shake up for the series in
addition to street fighter 6 capcom also
announced the capcom fighting collection
which includes 10 classic fighting games
it launches on june 24th for playstation
xbox switch and pc
we're just a day away from the launch of
destiny 2 the witch queen the game's new
dlc expansion and that means if you want
to prepare gather resources taking care
of some final tasks and experiencing all
the content that will be leaving the
game entirely well the clock's ticking
so how do you feel about the game's
power level increase i'm curious to hear
your thoughts on whether you're just
hopping in or if you're a destiny 2
veteran let me know in the comments and
as always leave a like subscribe and
come back tomorrow for more game spot
news
[Music]